this is they asked me the chair of the
session if most means I'll just be
timing people so we'll start with Josh
Berg thanks to come I'm just gonna
briefly mention that some of the work
and really present was done by three
very tower to posit from my lab I leave
my hey bie i-news and Jeff Pettibone and
I'm also gonna introduce or reintroduce
the idea there are different learning
systems in the brain that operate using
fundamentally different algorithms I'm
also going to totally ignore the
hippocampus because no one cares with
that specific system and I'm going to
talk about today it's really basal
ganglia centered and uses a
reinforcement learning algorithm and I'm
going to talk about what that means but
like the idea of introducing that
they're different organization of
circuits and microcircuit architecture
that specialized for extracting
different features of your experience
and processing them in different ways
and we've notice in one of the
introductions to this field comes from
maybe the 50s and the discovery there
were certain places in the brain that
you can wire up to a lever and latts
will rapidly learn to tickle their own
brains in certain places and not others
and while there are many places in the
brains that works they're really they're
trusted around the mesolimbic dopamine
system and the key thing to remember
about this situation is that rats we'll
both learn to push a lever to tickle
their own brains and then they'll be
highly motivated to go ahead and do it
again and again and again often with the
exclusion of other activities and I'm
gonna really go through the introduction
which slides fast because I'm sure most
people maybe everyone has heard about
this projection with famous projections
in the midbrain dopamine cell bodies
sending their axons to various forebrain
places but especially the stratum and
famous work they wore from shorts which
I promised illah I would not spend more
than a couple of minutes discussing
really a thing in the 80s and 90s showed
the following kind of phenomenon that
dopamine cell if you give up unexpected
squirt of fruit juice into the monkey's
mouth will fire a burst of spikes but as
that fruit juice squirt becomes
predicted expected the dopamine cell
stops responding to it and instead
responds to a queue that predicts that
juice so even though the monkey still
likes the juice and still avidly licks
the juice it open cell doesn't fire here
so so there and it's also not just about
making a prediction of future orders
about predictions in time so this is
tick marks of one dopamine self firing
and if you delay the juice you see a
pause and firing followed by a burst
when the juice comes if you bring the
juice too early you get the burst of
firing early and so forth alright so the
current high D dominant paradigm this
field is that dopamine cell signal a
reward prediction error so if you're
going to calculate a reward prediction
err you need a reward prediction right
and in turn the point of a reward
prediction error is to update your
predictions right it's a learning signal
it's there to do updating and you know
the way that this was conceived off by
people especially shorts wasn't there
was a sort of globally broadcast signal
from the midbrain to the forebrain
there was really all one big signal
scalar singing one reason why this has
been such a influential and powerful
paradigm just explains all kinds of
results and multiple levels of analysis
this is just one example from Kasai
group looking at growth of individual
spines on the dendrites of stride on
neurons and showing that if you have
this triple conjunction of glutamate
uncaging on to that spine and
postsynaptic depolarization and timed
dopamine input happening together then
you can cause the spine to grow in real
time you can see it growing alright and
the dopamine has to come in at just the
right time to make this happen within
about a second or so so one of the
reasons this has been a such a
successful marriage between your science
and computer science is that you can
actually do useful stuff with
reinforcement and it's become extremely
influential a lot of the current
developments in AI use reinforcement
learning in one way or another and some
that I'm you know especially in a
computing Institute I'm not qualified to
give a proper lecture on computing a
reinforcement learning but I'll just
give some very basic ideas you need to
know so the idea of an agent that can be
in one of the set of discrete different
states and each of these states has
associated value and a value is too far
here as an expectation of future reward
from that state discounted in time and
I'll come back to that if you transition
between states to a state with
unexpected value then that jump in value
is a reward prediction error there's
certain transition in values so you're
sitting around and some of your cue
comes on saying rewards coming up
all right you jumped to a different
state with different value that jump is
the reward prediction and then you use
that reward prediction to update the
values of states or states and actions
and as I mentioned this has become very
powerful and useful to do things like
beat me up go and so one way of thinking
about the brain or at least this sub
system within the brain that the
cerebral cortex is there to represent
states like what state am I in and to
distinguish discriminate different
states and then the Australian basal
ganglia is here to paint those states
with different values given I'm in this
state how much reward do I expect to get
and the point of the dopamine signals to
come in and modify the synapse is here
in order to modify update the weights
corresponding to values right
you can ask me to do a two-handed sign
what how can I use this one okay
challenge right so there's a problem
with us which is it this is a wonderful
absolutely wonderful framework but it
doesn't explain some of the core things
we know to be true about dopamine which
is dopamine is not just there as a
learning see there's lots of results
that sake dopamine also is motivating
energizing invigorating and it's really
important to emphasize that everyone
agrees that's true but there is no part
in this framework right so something
that's missing so one way of thinking
about this question is you have an agent
taking actions interacting in
environment and getting feedback about
the environment right so it's done it's
dopamine fundamentally about this
feedback this learning this updating
role or is it fundamentally about
motivating invigorating effects on
online ongoing performance is that
reasonably clear and if it does both of
those things how does the system not get
confused so if you are straight on
neurons say listening to dopamine we
know dopamine can do lots of things to
strongly affect synaptic plasticity that
showed you it would also change the
excitability of neurons affects many ion
channels so do you how do you know
whether to use dopamine as an
invigorating exciting signal or as a
synaptic plasticity signal or what so
the field has not really addressed this
properly but tends to do the following
says well dopamine does both of these
things but on different timescales
alright so fast so called phasic
fluctuations in dopamine are supposed to
be this reward prediction errors whereas
slower changes somehow do motivation and
no one who talks about tonic dopamine
ever ever defines what timescale they're
talking about they say whatever
timescale you're measuring with slow
techniques like my catalysis
so the specific more specific set of
ideas from there dawn Diane is that the
tonic dopamine level does not just
motivation in general but specifically
signals the rate at which you're getting
rewarded this is a useful thing if you
engage in some activity you're getting
three more words per minute
maybe that's worth continuing on more
than some other activity that already
gives you two rewards primitive all
right so it's a useful decision variable
deciding whether it's worthwhile to be
engaged in some tasks elapsed time some
of the data I'm with represent they're
trying to test some of these ideas and
most stuff in my lab not everything
looks like this there's a rat in a box
or some holes and some stuff in his head
and the task I'm going to talk about
looks like this a light comes on in one
of those halls and the rat has to stick
his nose in it and it takes them some
time to go and stick his nose in the
hole let's lit up I'm gonna call that
time the latency and then he waits there
and he's waiting for a variable period
of time and then he gets a joke Q which
is just white noise bursts and he pulls
out and he makes a choice you can stick
his nose in the left hole immediately to
the left or me look to the right and
sometimes as he enters that side hall he
hears a click which is the sound of a
sugar pellet being delivered behind him
then go eat it and it's a probable it's
a bandit task or probabilistically
rewarded task and the probabilities for
getting reward for choosing left or
right change every now and then without
telling the rat and yes you adapt his
behavior accordingly alright so in this
little sample of data here at all tick
means he got rewarded or short it means
he didn't so he tried left got a reward
tray and left again no reward left again
no reward let's try right no reward and
so forth and these are the nominal block
probabilities here so a full session of
behavior might look something like this
these are the changing probabilities of
reward and I hope you can see with a
little squinting that the rat is
adjusting his choices between left and
right to whichever option is better at a
given time but it's not just adjusting
his left right choices
he's also adjusting his motivation to
play the game so if we ignore whether it
was left or right and just look at the
density of rewards
sometimes he's getting a high density
reward
and sometimes the lower sorry I'm using
the sorry okay now you can really see
you're using a lower density rewards and
I'm the flipped scale here is the sort
of latency so when he's getting a high
density of rewards his latency to engage
in the next trial is shorter alright
this is one session of performance
easier to see this way is the reward
does the pellet remain in the bin until
he harvests it so then there is an
advantage to going to the 10% bin for
example I'm saying so it's not the case
that on each trial we give a reward
whether he goes now or not and then he
can go harvest it so he only gets
delivery of the ward if he makes that
choice okay so it's matching that
maximizing okay yes
yes that would change the model internal
model the animal would use the
interesting ways and we actually are
playing around with that but this way
it's very simple
so here's his adapting his choice so as
he enters a block of trials where left
is much better he switches his choices
over to left and vice versa for right
and here's his vigor latency data so if
he's got lots of rewards recently 10 out
of the last 10 were rewarded he's really
quick to initiate the next trial and if
he hasn't been role in any of the last
10 why should he bother he's really slow
to initiate the next ratios here what's
52 sorry yeah so 90 10 means that if he
chooses left there's a 90% chance he'll
get a reward and if you choose this
right there's only a 10% chance okay
what's 950 90/50 yep so it's 90 percent
chance versus a 50% chance okay so it
doesn't add 150 is higher
so if you compare ninety fifty to fifty
ten in both cases you're better off
going left right but nonetheless this
one will have a higher absolute chance
of getting reward right so this way what
you clowns you to dissociate this
process of making the better choice
versus how how valuable is that choice
is its Caritas has been used before to
pull apart action values versus the
choice itself so you know I just showed
you this thing saying that they're more
invigorated or more motivated when
they've received lots of rewards
recently but how does it actually work
and you can look at the latency data and
a set and break it down a different way
which is to say that after the light
comes on what's the survivor curve or
the hazard rate life hazard rate of it
initiating an approach behavior at each
moment in time and the way that reward
history affects its decision-making is
it changes the instantaneous likelihood
they'll decide to approach all right so
higher reward history means a greater
moment-by-moment chance he'll say okay
I'm gonna make the decision to to go for
it that makes sense so what now we have
this task where we have a reward rates
history and we have decisions to play
the game and we can see how to stoke
meaning involved in all of the stuff and
we measure dopamine in too many
different ways five I think six so I'm
just going to start by talking about a
couple of them so we use micro dialysis
which is historically a slow method but
has advantage of it's much more specific
to dopamine and to other things and the
way the fancy way we did it with Bob
Kennedy was to measure lots and lots of
things in the same one-minute time
resolution some okay so this is gonna be
a measure of tonic dopamine they also
use fast key and cyclic voltammetry
which is much faster as ten samples per
second it's focused on dopamine it has
its own idiosyncrasies it usually
doesn't work stuff
[Laughter]
we can talk about that so you know so
and this is just one example of one
sample recorded from the ventral
striatum here and you can measure pretty
much every major neurotransmitter at the
same time within a stratum and all their
metabolites and you can then test
various things that does this
concentration of each of these things in
a minute-by-minute sample vary with
things like the reward rate right so
this is just a simple correlation
between reward rate and dopamine and you
see among all these things only dopamine
and to a small extent the metabolites of
dopamine have this correlation with the
sheer density of rewards that you get so
this is something that is indeed seems
to correlate with rewarding it's highly
specific to totally right and it's not
about locomotor activity or explore
versus exploit for those who are into
these kinds of different ideas if you
just look at the total cumulative reward
which could correlate with time or
satiety or on any kind of things lots of
things care about that but dopamine does
not so an unpublished work we have sort
of extended this beyond the ventral
striatum in lots of different places in
the striatum and medial frontal cortex
and what we find is that this
correlation between a reward rate and
dopamine is seen specifically in the
accumbens core here and in the ventral
part of prema cortex here and if you go
more dorsally or eventually in the
frontal cortex you don't see it and if
you go more dorsally or eventually in
Stratham you don't see it either so this
is already a little inconsistent with
the sort of idea of a broadcast dopamine
signals something more specific is
happening in specific sub regions all
right hot spots of correlation between
dopamine and reward rate and one thing
that I'm not quite sure how much weight
to put on but I quite like this if you
do like meta analysis of human fMRI
studies and say which parts of the human
brain
consistently curl it with value
subjective value then you see two
hotspots which are in the ventral
striatum and the ventral medial
prefrontal cortex which seems to
correlate quite nicely to our rat
hotspots
so you know so far this seems consistent
with the idea that there's some tonic
dopamine signal that can go up and down
slowly and correlate with reward rate
but is it really what's going on is
there really something slow going on
that correlates with motivation and
reward rate and so we look at faster
signals as well with all territory and
it looks like this is the rat performing
the task one of the holes is going to
light up he's going to stick his nose in
it there you go
and then he's gonna make a left right
twist he went left all right
he heard a click you can go eat a sugar
pellet and meanwhile we're measuring to
the real-time patterns of dopamine
release in the a-comin score here right
okay that time he didn't hear his click
again
and then we can look at these
fluctuations and align them with
different events in the task obviously
we can say are there consistent
fluctuations that correct was light on
or Center in and what you see is a fast
ramping up of dopamine just as he
completes his approach and then if you
break up the data by whether he got a
reward or didn't so outside in he either
hears a click or he doesn't if he does
dopamine goes up fast if he doesn't
definitely goes down fast but the
highest the peak level of dopamine
within a trial if this task is as he
runs over to collect his reward dopamine
is getting up up up up up
and then as he grabs it dopamine goes
down first and you know obviously you
can look at whether this patent depends
upon his roared history and indeed if
he's got more rewards recently and then
you see a smaller increase in dopamine
sorry wrong pointer and if it's got very
few rewards then the same click of sugar
pellet delivery because it's a bigger
increase in time so this moment of time
seems somewhat consistent with world
prediction errors but other stuff
happening in the trial like as he
approaches to begin the trial or as he
goes to get his sugar panic don't seem
consistent with this general idea of a
reward prediction error right he's done
this task tens of thousands of times
why should going over to get his now
totally predicted sugar pellet we also
have any error associated with when we
first started trying to publish this
data we were very much thinking in terms
of reward prediction errors and one of
the things that sort of bugged me about
this is that it sort of seemed to go
down and then stay down bouncing back up
nicely and in fact it goes down it stays
down and I won't I wasn't cut out a few
slides about that but maybe I'll stick
him in at the end but basically it
doesn't really look like a reward
prediction what it pens let me come back
to that if you've still interested in
ten slides
I'm trying to compress it our long
talking to all right
so even though some aspects look like a
reward petitioner's other aspects don't
alright so and this seems consistent
with lots of other voluntary studies
right so his and ramping up fast ramp up
and dopamine as a rep gets ready to push
a lever for cocaine or for food and so
forth and here's another example
gravy oil and Paul Phillips showing a
rat running down a maze arm to collect a
fully predicted sugar pellet and
dopamine is ramping up as he runs down
the Mesa so people have sort of
contorted themselves trying to come up
with computational counsel which this
thing which doesn't really look like a
prediction error really could be a
prediction now but I don't find any of
those very convincing so story so fast
we have these fast fluctuations that
dopamine the company motivated approach
behaviors that's some relationship to
prediction error and we have this micro
Dallas thing about slowly measured
dopamine correlating with reward rate so
are these all different things or are
they one different aspects of the same
thing and obviously I wouldn't phrase it
that way unless I thought they were all
one for Josh can I ask a question so
this is still in the context of the
probabilistic times right and so what
you're saying is that you know yeah it's
been maybe this is a phase where there's
been a lot of you know sugar pellets at
one of the ports but nevertheless there
is a probabilistic element to it right
so there's lissome there's still some
degree of surprise or you know in the
tusks that we did I mean in some of the
other tasks like this one it really
wasn't any surprises it and so that even
so
okay and so you know in brief very brief
fashion I'm going to make the argument
that this fast fluctuations dopamine are
not signaling wrong prediction errors
they're singling reward predictions in a
form of a value function I think even
David mentioned value functions
yesterday so what do I mean by that this
is probably obvious to some people but
imagine the sort of abstract situation
where an agent has to pass through a
sequence of states while remembering to
use the right laser pointer in order to
get and these are unrewarded states in
order to get to a reward right well it
seems pretty obvious it's better to be
in state eight than state two because
state eight is closer to reward all
right so you can write the value of each
state as a time discounted expected
future reward yes good all right so the
state value the value of being status
how much reward you expect to get
discounted by time and in some ways the
point of an reinforcement learning
algorithm is to use your ongoing
experience to make estimates and adjust
the estimates of how much reward you
expect again and this is useful because
you have to make decisions is it worth
engaging in some activity well if you
have a higher expectation of reward
obviously it's better to agent it so
imagine the sequence where you're
uncertain about whether you gonna get a
reward so this is your value function
you're on the point-five curve and then
you get a Q and the Q says aha on this
trial you're definitely gonna get a
reward right so your value of being in
that state has just jumped up here right
and the amount of that jump is a reward
prediction error right so if you have a
higher expectation of reward and now you
find out yes definitely get a reward
it's not very surprising you jump up a
little bit you had a lower expectation
you get a bigger jump right so these are
so-called temporal difference reward
prediction errors they just are shifts
in the value function so if you can keep
track of value fast you also get the
reward prediction error and looks a bit
like the dopamine data but we could you
know the real task that we use is more
complicated because there are variable
delays and more events happening so we
made a model that evolved in real time
and we feed in the rats actual data
behavior into the model in order to
generate real-time estimates of reward
prediction errors and reward
it looks something like this the
particular set of states use doesn't
really matter just feed into that
behavior and you can do this you can
generate look at real-time dopamine
fluctuations and say do they look like
the state values of the model that are
evolving in real time or do they look
like the reward prediction errors and
the bottom line is they look a lot more
like the state values than they do like
the reward prediction errors so I just
made the argument to you that if you
keep track of value in real time you can
also use that as to calculate when your
prediction errors and use them for
learning but does the brain actually do
that
alright so one way we explore this is
through up to genetics
so if dopamine is being used as a
learning signal then if you mess with
dopamine fast then what should happen is
right now nothing but next time you
encounter the same situation your
behavior should be different that's what
I mean by learning right whereas if
dopamine's about motivation online
performance then messing with dopa
should affect behavior right now alright
and so we can look at that in the
following way so we can tickle dopamine
cells and measure consequent dopamine
release in the forebrain here blah blah
and we can give extra pulses of dopamine
of different moments within the trial
and see whether if we give dopamine at
the same time as we turn on this light
is he faster to engage in an approach
behavior just as if we boosted his
motivation just as if we'd increased his
expectation of reward right or
alternatively if we give extra dopamine
here as he finds out what he is going to
get a reward do we effectively boost a
reward prediction error and reinforce
his choice so if he goes right is he
more likely to go right on the next
trial
and in fact both of these things happen
so if you look at the hazard rate of
approach so this is a latency and hazard
rate so giving a poll a train of laser
pulses immediately within hundreds of
milliseconds effects is on line
motivated behavior makes them more
likely to engage in an approach it's not
a slow learning effect of any way
conversely we can reinforce this choices
so if we give a pulse of dopamine and
reward feedback to them on the next
trial he's more likely to make the same
choice again this doesn't happen and
littermate controls we can make it go
the other way with halorhodopsin
so we most most of what I show you so
far is published I showed you that
reward so that the dynamically change in
dopamine signal seems to fluctuate to
correspond to reward predictions much
more than prediction errors that these
dopamine signals used to make judgments
decisions about whether it's worthwhile
working or not the fluctuations of this
could be used as reward prediction
errors and we don't really believe in
these different time scales of dopamine
we think this just dopamine which is
fluctuating fast and it can be used for
both motivational and learning functions
so what we still have some problems
right we still want to account for the
shorts data this kind of thing saying
that dopamine cells in Cobra Ward
prediction errors even though dopamine
moves seems to do reward predictions so
what's up with that all right so a
couple things we've been thinking about
one is that you know the dopamine some
recordings have almost entirely been
performed in head fixed animals
performing Pavlovian tasks well they
really don't have anything to do except
sit there and wait for rewards
so maybe the need to work reflect is
reflected in the dopamine encoding the
value of work okay
the other possibility is that dopamine
self firing and reason were of really
different things and both of these seem
to be true so one way we've been
investigated by recording identified
dopamine cells using optogenetics
and here's just to sort of get
consonants with the shorts data we also
record the same cells in a more
Pavlovian task and if we give
unpredicted food cues these cells look
like shorts cells more or less they
respond to unexpected
we can record the same cells in our
Bandit task and see what happens when
you get reward queues or absence of
queues and the key things I want to
point out are the following so one is
that these cells together do a call do
encode a positive reward prediction
error right not a negative reward
prediction error for some reason the
strange we can talk about that well the
other thing is that the average firing
rate monotonic firing Lee doesn't care
about reward history at all right so we
have a situation where the tonic firing
or the firing of dopamine cells has no
relationship to reward history even
though dopamine release in the forebrain
does and one more example of the sort of
dissociation between dopamine firing and
dopamine release is seen here so as I
told you the animals are sitting and
waiting for the go queue and they wait a
variable amount of time so as the animal
wait the dopamine cells start firing
less and less and less and less and this
kind of thing has been seen before and
interpreted as a negative reward
prediction error right so as you waiting
for the cue your expectation that the
queue is going to happen in the next
moment is going up up up up right surely
it's gonna happen now right and so when
it doesn't happen you're more and more
disappointed it's more and more negative
all right said that so we can look at
this either with recording individual
cells or groups of cells and in this
fiber photometry experiment we've been
trying to simultaneously record dopamine
cell bodies in the VTA and their
terminals in the accumbens and seeing if
they're the same or different
using gcamp and using this method we
also see that the cell bodies are going
down down down down down down down
during this delay period possibly
reflecting a negative prediction error
but the terminals at the same neurons
are actually increasing no tivity more
like a reward prediction so we really
think this kind of thing is showing us
that control of dopamine terminals and
release is largely independent of
dopamine self firing and there's a whole
field of biology that needs to be
explored further so just to wrap up I
just said this dopamine for for many
definitions does not simply mirror
midbrain doping so firing
we think that local areas sculpt their
own dopamine release and we'd like to
know how this happens we'd like to know
whether straight on neurons are
switching modes sometimes using dopamine
as a learning signal and sometimes using
it as a motivation signal there's are
there many different functions of
dopamine in online behavioral control or
is there one way that we can
computationally bind these together and
the current working hypothesis we have
is that dopamine is signaling how
worthwhile it is to expend a limited
internal resource which could be energy
or attention basal ganglia there's this
body configuration there's a gin where
the little mouse learns at four key
processes of macro so I'm just wondering
if that if the configuration of the body
is a compound purpose some of your stuff
and also I were this is a knife naive
question but I always thought there's
lots of flavors of dopamine in there and
how do you know that you've got the
right flavor strawberry flavor I maybe
I'm not fully understanding what you
mean by a flavor I mean I understand
they're like sure so absolutely so
they're different receptors that listen
to dopamine yeah absolutely
and so I can certainly talk about how
those receptors are listening to
dopamine there's been an idea that the
sub d2 receptors are listening to so
steady levels of dopamine they some
evidence has true something that's not
but either way when you're a d1 receptor
bearing cell d2 you still have this
problem right which is what does
dopamine mean to you right now okay so
you could be trying to separate out
these by one set of cells cares about it
as motivation there they're learning but
you know they both have to undergo
synaptic plasticity in both cases they
have the same fundamental synaptic
dendritic architecture they both have
similar learning rules so I think
dopamine is modulating plasticity on
both of those cell populations
so how are you sociated opening neuron
firing dopamine knows how we dissociate
how you imagine dissociated things you
mean how do I imagine that cells could
just mean if your target someone's tried
them you have no idea what's happening
with firing in the midbrain you just
know how much what the instantaneous
concentration of dopamine is right I
thought when sulphides an action
potential huh that action potential
propagates Lennar how old-fashioned of
you so dopamine terminals of all kinds
of receptors themselves right so for
example they have kolodziejczak
receptors nicotinic and we know that
even if you don't have a if you take a
slice of strider but no midbrain present
then if you flash a star choline
optogenetic lee you get dopamine release
right so there are lots of ways by which
you can control dopamine and released
locally and I should have been more
specific about that sorry we also know
for example that the basal lateral
amygdala input to ventral striatum can
control dopamine release even if you
inactivate VTA so yes there are
mechanisms that have been known about
for decades for local control of
dopamine release they've just never
entered into the computational theories
does that mean that if you were to block
local release let's say by one then you
still get the reward prediction aspect
yeah well we've been trying to find the
right ways to do to to get at that right
so we've been trying for example to put
you know carbon fibers for voltammetry
on optic fibers for control of
cholinergic cells and things like that
there's so much fast regulation in the
system you know that we don't even know
the status of the coverage of receptors
whether the desensitize normally so so
much is unknown about the status of
these things in behaving animals that
you know partly we're trying things and
partly won't like us too hard
yeah I'm not quite clear association
between the release and the chlorine
yeah so I mean I actually think that the
basic short story of a reward prediction
a signal is right right that you can use
fast fluctuations as reward prediction
error signals but I think it's only half
the story so I think sometimes the
striatum listens to this as a learning
signal and sometimes it uses a
motivation signal and I think for
example the kolodziejczak interneurons
are really important in switching modes
right so for example the color jaques
usually fire steadily and then have
brief pauses a couple hundred
milliseconds maybe gern we'll talk about
that right and then during those pauses
you unblock synaptic plasticity so
there's evidence for switching into a
running mode very transiently then
switching back and we think when you
switch back now you use it to gate
excitability of well I think if you get
a burst of firing of dopamine cells you
still usually get a pulse of dopamine
release but it's a tricky deciphering
job that has to be done at the level of
the forebrain and we only have the
beginning of a sense of how that might
work
[Applause]